[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit mir
triebe serien zwei tage bevor die
weihnachtstage beginnen ihnen allen
einen schönen guten abend kristin otto
hat heute unter anderem treffsichere
nachrichten vom sport einen richtigen
volltreffer guten abend und das haben
wir heute unter anderem für sie
vorbereitet
wie umgehen mit omikron
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hofft es
geht auch ohne lockdown lkw chef will
errechnet mit einer verschärfung der
lage
impfen per gesetz der ethikrat spricht
sich mehrheitlich für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht aus fordert aber auch mehr
aufklärung und impfangebot
und mit pfeil und herz bei der darts wm
in london steht florian hempel völlig
überraschend in der dritten runde
ja es war schon einigermaßen
bemerkenswert gestern das
robert-koch-institut empfahl strengere
coroner regeln möglichst sofort
gesundheitsminister lauterbach in dessen
verantwortungsbereich das rkw feld war
darüber nicht begeistert denn er
beschlossen mit der bund länder runde
erst nach weihnachten weitere maßnahmen
verpflichtend einzuführen insofern
gespannte blicke zur heutigen
gemeinsamen pressekonferenz von rk ii
chef und gesundheitsminister andreas
künast
der chef des robert koch instituts hat
sein unbehagen gestern gezeigt so
überraschend und so überraschend
deutlich hat lothar wieler us-behörde
schärfste beschränkungen gefordert dass
die bund länder beschlüsse prompt
schwach aussagen der chef von lothar
wieler zeigt sein unbehagen heute als
unabgestimmt als nicht optimal
kritisiert karl lauterbach vilas
stellungnahme aber schwach lässt der
gesundheitsminister den behördenchef
nicht aussehen hier kamen jetzt mal die
frage ob ich zu einem wlan noch stehe
das lässt sich leicht beantworten sonst
sehr sehr er ihn nicht auch wieder
spielt die differenzen herunter und
wiederholt seine forderung nach
sofortigen maximalen kontakt
beschränkungen so nicht das
weihnachtsfest soll aber nicht der funke
sein der das omikron feuer entfacht im
gegenteil kanzler scholz und die
ministerpräsidenten hatten gestern abend
vereinbart dass kontakt beschränkungen
die schließung von clubs und das verbot
von großveranstaltungen erst nach
weihnachten in kraft treten müssen wir
haben die erfahrung gemacht rheinland
pfalz das ihm einschränkenden maßnahmen
und die appelle sehr gut angenommen
werden von den menschen weihnachten ist
ein großes großes privates fest und
unsere beobachtung es in rheinland pfalz
sehr verantwortlich mit umgehen andere
länder wollen die möglichkeit nutzen
teile des öffentlichen lebens früher zu
schließen
mecklenburg-vorpommern gehört zu den
ländern die leider ein hohes
infektionsgeschehen haben unsere
krankenhäuser sind mit
intensivstationen absolut am limit und
deshalb müssen wir so schnell wie
möglich diese kontakt beschränkung
einsätzen am tag danach hätte lothar
wieler die bund länder beschlüsse loben
können aber
ob ich zufrieden oder unzufrieden ist
ist völlig irrelevant die zwei obersten
pandemie bekämpfer erklären einander ihr
unbehagen aber heute zumindest nicht
öffentlich
wir gehen nach berlin zu theo koll theo
gesundheitsminister und rk ii haben sich
ja größte mühe gegeben ihren streit
runter zu kochen wie darf man das
einschätzen nun wir eben zitierte satz
von professor wieder dass das
weihnachtsfest nicht der funke sein soll
wer das mikro feuer entfacht der satz
kann auch durchaus auf das verhältnis
von minister und der ak-chef angewandt
werden bitte nicht weiter entflammen
aber wieder hat seinen punkt ja gestern
sehr deutlich gemacht maximale kontakt
beschränkungen und zwar sofort das war
in klarer abgrenzung zu den aussagen des
ministers und zu denen dann folgenden
politischen beschlüssen ich glaube man
darf zu recht davon ausgehen dass der
lkw chef seit wochen erkennbar die
geduld verliert weil zu viele den ernst
der lage nicht erkennen oder erkennen
wollen und auch aus dem expertenrat hört
man übrigens dass die beschlossenen
maßnahmen nicht zur dringlichkeit der
lageanalyse passen aber wahrscheinlich
sind die meisten menschen an weihnachten
eher vorsichtig auch vor dem 28 dezember
und ganz ohne politische vorschriften
danke nach berlin theo koll ja fest
steht um das hohe impft embo in
deutschland beizubehalten soll es auch
während der feiertage die möglichkeit
geben sich impfen zu lassen und allein
gestern haben 1,1 millionen menschen
eine spritze erhalten
rein statistisch während das 13
impfungen pro sekunde damit sind
inzwischen
73,6 prozent der gesamtbevölkerung
mindestens einmal geimpft
33,8 prozent haben auch die auffrischung
bekommen die seit gestern deutlich
früher empfohlen wird alles weitere von
oliver deuker
eigentlich sollte im stadion von
hannover 96
weihnachtliches singen stattfinden doch
wegen kroner wurde aus der not eine
tugend gemacht impfen stadt singen heißt
es jetzt der andrang ist groß zumal seit
gestern die stiko das booster nun schon
nach drei monaten empfiehlt 1800
anmeldungen liegen vor ich hätte jetzt
normalerweise eben eine vier monate
herum gehabt und wir bekommen aber die
stichworte mich schon mit dem schluss
ich wollte hier einzustellen bei mir ist
genau
300 monate bei mir wäre es januar
februar soweit habe ich sehr gut dann
bin nichts von hannover probier es hier
und ich finde es eine super aktion jeder
pigs zählt man trat ich wiederholen dass
politiker und virologen das mitte
november gesetzte ehrgeizige ziel bis
ende des jahres 30 millionen menschen zu
impfen wohl machbar
wir haben tatsächlich auch in der
vergangenheit in einem selbst für mich
fast überraschenden tempo diese booster
impfungen hinbekommen ich kann ihnen
sagen stand gestern sind wir bei knapp
28 millionen 100.000 und es soll weiter
gehen auch an den feiertagen gibt es
bundesweit im angebot das nächste ziel
bis ende januar noch mal 30 millionen
impfungen die kapazitäten sollen
vorhanden seien
25 millionen impfdosen im ersten quartal
die zusätzlich zu den bestellmengen die
wissen wieso schon da waren bestellt
worden sind zeigt glaube ich sehr
deutlich dass wir in einer region sind
wo genau das auch erreicht werden kann
das muss es auch sonst platzt die
hoffnung omikron und die anrückende
fünfte welle in schach zu halten
ja soeben haben wir noch die
impfwilligen im blick jetzt geht es eher
um die impfwilligen seit monaten wird
dieses thema hoch emotional diskutiert
eine teil im pflicht nur für bestimmte
berufsgruppen ist ja schon beschlossen
aber ob es auch allgemein verpflichtend
werden soll darüber wird ja noch
debattiert für eine ausweitung der
impfpflicht spricht sich heute der
deutsche ethikrat aus wien iaea
berichtet es geht um freiheit
gerechtigkeit
selbstbestimmung um das risiko anderen
großen schaden zuzufügen der ethikrat
war bislang gegen eine impfpflicht die
faktenlage aber ändere die position man
braucht einfach sehr hohe impfquoten
wenn man diese pandemie dauerhaft
überwinden will und nicht immer wieder
in diese auch gefährlichen wellen kommen
möchte in denen die intensivstation
überlastet sind in denen man das land
wieder runter fahren muss
da ist sicherlich die impfpflicht kein
allheilmittel das muss auch klar sein
aber ohne impfen wird es nicht gehen es
müsse genügend impfmöglichkeiten geben
den impfstoff sollte man sich aussuchen
dürfen man solle persönlich
angeschrieben werden ganz einig sind
sich die experten aber nicht manche
wollen eine impfpflicht nur für
besonders gefährdete gruppen vier von 24
mitgliedern denen eine impfpflicht ganz
ab wir wissen nicht wann diese
impfpflicht denn einsetzen würde wie oft
wir impfen müssten wir wissen aber auch
nicht wie wir letztlich diese
impfpflicht den durchsetzen wollten wir
also sicherstellen können dass es
irgendwie eine eine dann auch ihre ziele
erreichen de maßnahme wäre und nicht
eine die zwar existiert aber in der
sache mehr ärger als nutzen bringt der
bundestag soll im neuen jahr entscheiden
ohne die sonst übliche
fraktionsdisziplin
es hat sich bei medizin ethischen fragen
ja bewährt und der die stellungnahme des
ethikrates einfach ein wichtiger beitrag
zur debatte und zur meinungsbildung der
einzelnen kolleginnen und kollegen wir
haben da keine zeit zu verlieren die
bundesregierung ist ein dicken gekommen
eine frontstellung zwischen geimpften
und ungeimpften solle vermieden werden
sagt der ethikrat auch dass es nun die
herausforderung für die politik eine
generelle impfpflicht hatten alle
verantwortlichen lange ausgeschlossen
dann schauen wir auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen die noch nicht von der
bevorstehenden mikrowelle geprägt sind
aktuell meldet das robert-koch-institut
1659 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind
5642 weniger als vor einer woche
allerdings ist die zahl der todesfälle
hoch 510 innerhalb eines tages die
sieben tage incidents sinkt auf 0
alle die eine corona infektion
überstanden haben die werden als genesen
eingestuft aber das bedeutet noch lange
nicht gesund nach einer aktuellen studie
klagen bis zu 40 prozent der infizierten
auch ein halbes jahr später noch über
symptome die auf longo wird hindeuten zb
müdigkeit kurzatmigkeit
herzrhythmusstörung jeder dritte
infizierte klagt über eine verminderte
leistungsfähigkeit
cornelia schiemenz hat patienten besucht
die es sehr schlimm traf im sächsischen
vogtland woco wird besonders stark
grassiert
lungenfunktionstest immer wieder heiko
müller erkrankte letztes weihnachten
schwer an corona koma
herz-lungen-maschine reha das volle
programm
und auch ein jahr später ist der 51
jährige noch immer schwer gezeichnet das
mittlere herausforderung
zwei treppenabsätze und dann geht nichts
mehr immer mehr longo wird patienten
melden sich in der praxis von dr walter
im vogtländischen auerbach
patienten die als genesen gelten aber
noch lange nicht wieder gesund sind
erschöpfung gedächtnislücken herz
kreislauf probleme und die angst dass
das alte leben nie wieder zurückkommt es
gibt keine spezifische therapie für
diese
ostkurve patienten also wir können noch
so tief arbeiten also unterstützend und
können durch medikamentöse therapie
speziell der symptome die der patient
bietet da eingreifen heiko müller ist
seit einem jahr arbeitsunfähig wenn er
glück hat wird ja ehemalige
marathonläufer vielleicht mal 90 prozent
seines lungenvolumen es zurückbekommen
das leben wollen und eventuell mal mit
kanutour mit meinem sohn unternehmen
heiko müller freut sich auf die
bevorstehenden feiertage und versucht
ganz bewusst die erinnerungen an das
letzte weihnachtsfest zu verdrängen
die fdp hat sich für eine zweite
amtszeit von bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier ausgesprochen das gab
parteichef lindner am abend in berlin
bekannt die liberalen fraktionen in bund
und land hätten dafür plädiert den
sozialdemokraten zu unterstützen
steinmeier sei eine herausragende
persönlichkeit und habe sich in zeiten
gesellschaftlicher polarisierung um den
zusammenhalt in unserem land verdient
gemacht
studieren soll nicht mehr so sehr vom
geldbeutel der eltern abhängig sein sagt
die neue fdp bildungsministerin stark
watzinger und kündigte eine schnelle
bafög reform an sie soll unter anderem
eine starthilfe für studienanfänger aus
ärmeren familien umfassen bislang erhält
etwa jeder zehnte studierende eine
staatliche förderung von palo jetzt mit
mehr
gleiche bildungschancen für alle dafür
wurde das bafög eingeführt doch in der
praxis steht der bildungskredit immer
wieder in der kritik nicht nur wegen der
höhe und je nach studiengang und
beruflicher aussicht danach kann es
relativ schwierig sein das
zurückzuzahlen sie jetzt wenn man sich
anschaut wie die inflationsrate da
sollte man eventuell auch den bafög satz
dementsprechend anpassen
861 euro monatlich ist der höchstsatz
doch der ist vor allem abhängig vom
einkommen der eltern das möchte die
bildungsministerien ändern wir müssen
also das bafög moderner machen flexibler
der lebensrealität angepasst das ist der
eine punkt und der andere punkt
elternunabhängige das heißt es kommt
nicht auf das elternhaus sondern auf das
talent an was ich machen kann schlechte
karten haben bislang auch die die zu
lange studieren die
förderungshöchstdauer firma flug liegt
bei der regelstudienzeit in der
regelstudienzeit schafft aber nur noch
ein drittel der studierenden das studium
das heißt viele haben das problem dass
kurz vor dem abschluss ihn womöglich die
studienfinanzierung wegbricht die zahl
der bafög-empfänger sinkt immer weiter
nach einem höchststand im jahr 2012 fiel
die zahl auf zuletzt
639.000 nur noch elf prozent aller
studierenden damit künftig wieder mehr
vom bafög profitieren soll es schon
kommendes wintersemester höhere
freibeträge bei den einkommen geben für
einkommensschwache ein starterpaket für
erst anschaffungen wie einen laptop und
studienkredite der kaffee sollen
vorübergehend zinsfrei bleibt wichtig
ist aber auch dass sie finanziell
kräftig ausgestaltet wird denn nur so
können wir viele studierende erreichen
also es muss eine bafög-reform bei
nachdem bundeskanzler olaf scholz mit
wumms werden es wird sich zeigen ob die
reform die trendwende reiten kann
das land hessen ist um rund 100
millionen euro reicher grund dafür ist
ein ermittlungserfolg aus dem jahr 2009
10 damals schalteten die behörden im
dark knight dem verborgenen
internetbereich eine der weltweit
größten plattformen für drogen und
andere illegale waren ab umgesetzt
hatten die drei verurteilten ihr
geschäft mit crypto währungen die hatte
das land erst beschlagnahmt und jetzt
verkauft warum gab es bei der
flutkatastrophe im sommer in nordrhein
westfalen keinen krisenstab um hilfen
zentral zu koordinieren
um diese und weitere fragen geht es beim
untersuchungsausschuss des düsseldorfer
landtages heute sagte der derzeitige
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst aus der
damalige verkehrsminister erklärte er
habe sich umgehend um den wiederaufbau
der zerstörten
verkehrsinfrastruktur gekümmert er habe
dem damaligen ministerpräsidenten
laschet aber nicht vorgeschlagen einen
krisenstab zu bilden auch laschet soll
noch aussagen
und jetzt kommen zu einer grossen
überraschung im sport christin superding
florian hempel heißt der mann der bei
der weltmeisterschaft im alexandra
palace von london zum favoritenschreck
avanciert zweite runde 3 2 1 triumph
über den favorisierten belga van den
bergh selbst für experten eine sensation
florian hempel war bei seinem sieg über
den weltranglisten fünften dimitri van
den bergh unfassbar nerven stark er
kontert fast jeden angriff des mit-
favoriten auf den wm titel der erste
satz die mit knapp 380 an hab ich mir
gedacht okay
warte warte lauer auf deine chance und
die chance kommt hempel gleicht
ausliefert 180 punkte geht und führung
und ohne mit der wimper zu zucken wirft
er die doppel 16 zum satzgewinn
auch der dritte satz geht an den 31
jährigen der trotz hochspannung alipay
ich ganz cool bleibt den vierten satz
zum matchgewinn sichert sich hempel
sogar zu null van den bergh ohne chance
florian hempel feiert weihnachten jetzt
in london weil danach runde drei ansteht
noch darf mit publikum in den deutschen
ligen gespielt werden aber in sechs
tagen ist es wieder vorbei mit der
unterstützung von den rängen kein
anfeuern kein applaus vor allem den
vereinssport treffen die erneuten kroner
maßnahmen hat
ab dem 28 12 wird es hier in der halle
recht ruhig sein das ist seit gestern
klar denn die fans müssen draußen
bleiben wegen der rasanten ausbreitung
der nikon variante keine stimmung
weniger einnahmen gerade die
hallensportarten aber leben zu einem
großteil von den zuschauereinnahmen
außerdem so mahnen kritiker bestehe eine
erhebliche gefahr für die
vereinslandschaft in deutschland da sind
strukturen aufgebaut über jahrzehnte die
weit über den profi sport hinausgehen
die eine soziale wirkung haben und wenn
die drohen wegzubrechen die kann man
nicht mal wieder schnell wieder aufbauen
der politik ist dieses dilemma bewusst
das programm corona hilfen profisport
wurde bereits verlängert zudem soll
anfang januar die lage neu bewertet
werden
günter kurz der hinweis den
weltcup-slalom der männer in italien
gibt es als livestream von viertel von 9
an in der heute dann dankeschön christin
und wir machen jetzt hier mit einem
spanischen klassiker weiter und zwar mit
der ältesten lotterie der welt seit 200
jahren hoffen spanier alljährlich auf el
gordo den dicken
172 mal wird der hauptgewinn der
traditionelle weihnachtslotterie
ausgezahlt der beträgt in diesem jahr
dicke 4 millionen euro und sämtliche
gezogenen losnummern werden von kindern
gesungen
[Musik]
schönes vorweihnachtliches ritual im
altehrwürdigen madrider opernhaus und es
begeistert längst nicht nur die
glücklichen gewinner
wer weiß vielleicht klappt es ja auch
bei ihnen beim mittwochslotto die
gewinnzahlen lauten 13 33 37 40 46 48
und die superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen
auf lotto zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7 beim wetter könnte ich werden
es gibt regen es gibt schnee details hat
gleich katja honnefer
gesundheitsminister lauterbach später im
heute-journal interview mit marietta
slomka ab 21 45 lassen sie sich bitte so
kurz vorm fest nicht mehr stressen danke
fürs zuschauen zu den abend und bis
morgen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt bewegung ins wetter denn
das tief pia vertreibt das hoch anni die
hohen wolken kamen schon heute an und
die breiten sich jetzt im laufe des
abends und in der nacht lieber ganz
norddeutschland aus im süden ist es
dagegen noch mal klar oder es bildet
sich wieder nebel und die temperaturen
sinken auf werte zwischen minus 1 und
minus 13 grad morgen wirds dann in der
osthälfte meist so 0 bis 4 grad geben im
westen wird es milder am mildesten am
oberrhein mit neun grad und es wird
spannend denn es kommen regen und
schneeregen und vor allen dingen
glatteisregen wolken heran morgen
vormittag wird also gefährlich besonders
in niedersachsen und auch im nördlichen
nordrhein westfalen im laufe des
nachmittags erreichen schnee regen und
glatteis regenwolken dann auch den
nordosten die gefährlichste region die
zwei hier zwischen dem thüringer wald
und der nordseeküste ganz anders sieht
es im südwesten aus da bleibt es den
ganzen tag über freundlich dann kommt
der heiligabend und damit schneit es in
mecklenburg-vorpommern im laufe des
nachmittags ziehen diese schneewolken
weiter nach südwesten in der nacht zum
ersten feiertag erreicht der schnee dann
auch hamburg und berlin und am ersten
feiertag selbst schneit es noch über den
mittelgebirgen machen sie sich auf
glatte straßen gefasst